- Un petit 10 minutes qui
pourrait sauver jusqu'à 3 vies.
Alors que l'été bat son plein,
Héma-Québec prévient que
ses réserves de sang diminuent.
ALEX TRÉPANIER, superviseur,
Globule de Québec-Sainte-Foy
- Présentement, la situation
du don de sang, elle est pas
inquiétante, mais par contre,
elle est préoccupante.
Comme c'est l'été et que
tout le monde est en vacances,
on a un 500 dons de plus à faire
ine par centre.
- C'est chez les groupes
sanguins A+ et A- que
les besoins sont les plus
importants. La reprise
des voyages à l'étranger est
l'un des facteurs qui expliquent
la baisse des réserves cet été.
JOSÉE LARIVÉE,
porte-parole, Hema-Québec
- Il y a un impact un peu
partout, c'est-à-dire
qu'on a l'habitude des basses
réserves en saison estivale.
Les Québécois ont pris d'assaut,
cette année, les aéroports,
surtout après deux ans
de pandémie, donc l'absence
se fait sentir malheureusement.
- Mégane Lemieux est
une donneuse régulière
depuis l'an dernier.
Elle en est à son 20e don.
MÉGANE LEMIEUX, donneuse
- Je trouve tellement que c'est
une cause qui est importante,
il y a tellement de gens ont
besoin de produits sanguins
à chaque année.
- Comme elle, Stéphane Morin
a fait du don de sang
une habitude. Il en a déjà
donné plus de 450 fois.
STÉPHANE MORIN, donneur
- Pour moi, c'est important
parce que je sais que
j'aide les autres,es autres,es ,
puis ça m'aide aussi.
- Pour ceux qui hésitent
à prendre un rendez-vous,
Héma-Québec vous conseille
d'inviter vos prohces à tenter
l'expérience avec vous.
- Souvent, on a des groupes
qui se présentent, soit
des familles, des amis.
Des gens qui prennent
rendez-vous ensemble pour
se motiver à venir nous voir.
- La réserve de sang appartient
à tous les Québéc pas
Héma-Québec qui a besoin de
sang, ce sont les Québécois
qui ont besoin de sang.
- Héma-Québec invite tous
les adultes intéressés à faire
un don de sang à se rendre sur
son site web pour vérifier
s'ils y sont admissibles
et pour prendre rendez-vous.
Ici Flavie Sauvageau,
Radio-Canada, Qué